30 000
90 day fiance alum stephanie motto is
back with a new business venture
and this time around she's selling her
sweat
so people already just question okay
well why is this girl doing this
yeah you could say that's the vibe right
now
because in a video posted to tick-tock
she reveals she's made
thousand dollars in just one week
thirty thousand
if you're wondering how you may remember
stephanie it's because this is a
follow-up gig to her viral fame
in 2021 the reality star made a shocking
announcement
stephanie claimed she made over 100 000
for selling her farts in jars and ever
since my last tick tock went viral i've
been getting a lot of questions such as
who buys my farts and why
but following a serious health scare
that landed her in the hospital due to
eating too many gas inducing foods
stephanie was forced to stop the bizarre
business venture
and these are just the latest stops on
stephanie's journey to fame which she
kicked off by starring on 90 day fiance
before the 90 days and i just cannot
wait to see erica stephanie made history
when she was part of the first same-sex
couple to be featured on the hit tlc
series
she is the most beautiful
best-smelling
best-dressed most amazing human being
can i say
back in 2020 she opened up to et about
sharing her romantic life with audiences
i feel like there's a lot of pressure
you know you don't want to let down
anybody you don't want to let down the
lgbt community and
a part of me wants to be like great
representation for this community but
also
i think
we all just need to realize we're just
like any other couple we're gonna have
just you know similar problems to all
the other couples on the show and i hope
that people you know come into this with
an open mind and you know
give us a chance to share our story and
see that there are some similarities but
also maybe some differences too that
we'll have to deal with as far as our
relationship but
i'm super excited it's crazy this feels
so surreal this is a huge
moment coming out for me i'm a
storyteller
and
i like being open and honest and
vulnerable because i want to make other
people feel less alone and i want other
people to feel understood because for
such a long time i felt really
misunderstood like i really felt that
nobody knew really who i was or what i
was going through
and you know there's a lot of stigma in
the lgbt community but there's also a
lot of stigma for bisexuals
for a lot of people it's not taken
seriously
even within the lgbt community it's like
oh you know like why can't you just
choose why don't you just decide are you
intimate are you into women but i'm
really
proud and happy that we are going to be
the first couple that is going to be
kind of unveiling all these issues and
showing the world what it's really like
[Music]